tu es ma gueule
[Applaudissements]
la golf grande joie énorme offriront
franchement et c'est toi c'est lui qui a
tout fait même chaque couleur c'est lui
qui l'a fait
vous savez ce que c'est cette couleur c3
décoloration ouais j'ai les cheveux trop
noir donc ça prend trop de temps à venir
on nettoie les colorations sont
respectueux sort après te fais ça sur la
tête ça c'est un truc de ouf as tu
reçois même abad bout en bout d'un
besoin des doigts de décoloration
windhager d'avoir la calvitie mois après
n'ont pas fait est-ce que je peux
regarder ta qualité tu veux tu peux me
salir les toits qualité excellente non
franchement tu as une qualité toyas n'y
arrive pas d'effort je sais que tu vas
faire en rentrant chez toi tu vas mettre
de l'huile de ricin avachi phonéthon
cheveux comme ceci tu vas voir que ton
cheveux va va vivre ses torts python
coiffeurs ses
roland bras et franchement refait le
traitement scène jeanne d'arc
si refait le trait doit on le traîne on
mène 1-0 alors ça fait trop footeux
j'adore le très bas mais c'est vrai fois
son frère comme ça fais moi plaisir je
peux le refaire a tout de suite su
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
lui même ce que je te fais je te fais
une petite reine ont bien la vérité si
je te cite une fin très je te fais un
très jeune à [ __ ]
ces traits pour traits dent pour dent
mois jean marc à la merci en tout cas
vous sur zone avec votre public
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
là bas ils ont fait un rouleur relou la
dame tu vois il est allé rejoindre las
tablas et la balle à sa galerie nouv
on vas voir tu réfléchis tu sais où
trouver je suis là encore c'est qu'il
veut rester ici moi non plus je te
rappelle que j'étais une relation je te
rappelle que j'ai tout nouveau clip à m
assois devoir maintenant